when i saw the picture of you with your
new abs your eight pack you know because
you've been working out
i said that must have been a big
decision for you when the photographer
says hey man
lift up your shirt and show us your abs
because you're a comedian
and you think about everything and you
look at everything
was that a big decision for you i guess
like my makeup artist and a couple of
people was like you know you
you know you look good i'm not kevin
harding it's
who i also love dear right uh joe
piscopo again
i promise you that's the last time
you'll see my abs
remember like older actresses used to
pose in playboy because it's like okay
let me get let me document that i look
good
yeah like no matter what when i'm 80
i'll be able to go hey i was hot for a
minute come
on it's one of those things too it's
like i've been insecure about
my body for years and it's like
you know this good thing about the
quarantine it's like learn well
do something about it like your body
your body isn't like
this thing you can't change right
it's hard right you can change it so
half of it was working out but the other
half was i was i learned to swim
so between you know slip you know
swimming when you're
50 dude forget it i'm trying to get
yacht ready
i'm just trying yeah yeah swimming's not
it's a physical feat but it's a lot of
just
letting go because you float naturally
you know
not as much when you're black but you
still like it
really yeah yeah we have buoyancy issues
for chris what is it like this is true
this is true robin look it up
look it up chris when i saw you were in
this great shape this is a good time to
put this out there
i'm single is there anybody who you've
seen
i'm talking about actresses anyone i'm
not even gonna
i'm not even gonna say no you know what
i'll say because i did
you know cause she did she just
announced that she's seeing somebody so
yeah i definitely you know you let you
let hallie know what's up
really you're gonna you go to paris you
gotta go to the eiffel tower right